how will that speech have gone down very
well I mean that hits all the buttons
that the Japanese investment Community
want to hear continued British
government support for Japanese
investment in the UK particularly in the
areas the Prime Minister concentrated on
for infrastructure Renewables climate
adaptation and continued government
support for the trading relationship
which is important to both parties I
think he was speaking there to an
audience of Japanese and British
businessmen and trade and investment is
at the heart of the bilateral
relationship and they want to hear the
Prime Minister reaffirm that looking at
the numbers though trades not done that
well over the previous few years going
down on every occasion since 2019
according to the latest 2017 latest
figures I'm looking at and the last
major trade deal with Japan and that was
that fell from 12.3 billion to
11.9 billion in the year to the end of
uh June last year Well trade agreements
don't make trade they facilitate a
framework where trade can happen trade
depends upon the economy and the
strength of the economy and both the
Japanese and the British economies have
been through the wars a bit in the last
couple of years with the pandemic and
there is also the brexit factor and I
make that point to say only that
Japanese companies who had invested in
the UK up to 2016 because we were part
of the European Union are still
committed to being here but are shifting
their own business
Frameworks more to concentrating
headquarters sales marketing
distribution networks Etc in Europe
as well as having a presence in Britain
all of that has an impact on trade uh I
think we will see as the economies grow
again and the Japanese economy is
beginning to grow quite strongly that
trade will pick up my experience over 30
years of promoting trade and investment
in Japan is that it's usually a function
of economic strength and economic growth
so two thoughts from that first of all
the fact that there are now two centers
if you will one in the UK and one in
Europe is what you're suggesting with
particularly the car industry
um from your experience your three
decades are the ones that are presently
in the UK likely to dwindle on the vine
they already have dwindled a little
since 2016. I think what the prime
minister is announcing is a Resurgence
of investment in certain areas where the
British economy is moving ahead fast
particularly on Renewables uh there's um
there's a desire on the part of the
Japanese to have as much frictionless
trade as possible between Britain and
Europe they made that very clear in 2016
after the referendum and that I'm sure
is in the in the minds of British
government ministers as for example they
deal with the recent
complaints by the car industry
um about access to batteries it's
interesting that Nissan of course which
is you know the the company which made
the weather in terms of Japanese
investment back in 1984 has its own
battery production supply chain up in
the Northeast and was a less prominent
part of the car Industries application
to the government to renegotiate the
brexit terms I think Japanese companies
are pragmatic they want to stay in
Britain because they know as the Prime
Minister has reaffirmed that Britain is
a very supportive environment for
Japanese investment not just corporation
tax but skills infrastructure and so
forth this relationship is very strong
and I think it will stay strong Japan's
economy um I think a technical term was
a basket case for quite a long time what
what can we learn from the Japanese to
improve our economy Basket Case is far
too strong but I remember British
government ministers coming to Japan in
the bad years and saying if this is
recession I'd like some in my
constituency because it is still a
Powerhouse in terms of innovation
technology and uh and and consumer
choice but what can we learn from the
Japanese economy well we can learn about
the importance of companies run by
Engineers who have an eye to Innovation
about companies run from the perspective
of serving a wider range of stakeholders
in the community rather than simply
concentrating on the bottom line and
profits quarter by quarter there is a
longer term emphasis in Japanese
business culture which I think is
something we we can all learn from and
there's also I think a lower level of
inequality between those on the top
salaries and those on the bottom
salaries Japan it's a capitalist Society
but it's a more Equitable capitalist
Society than many
um talking about the culture
um the prime minister is going to
Hiroshima later on of course people of a
certain age will very much remember
Hiroshima even though I believe Kyoto
was the original Target if I'm not
mistake I think I think uh they well
they they were there was a talk of the
bombing Kyoto but because of its
historic status I think um the American
government during the war decided not to
and so they concentrated on Hiroshima
which is quite a contained City and
Nagasaki yes yeah does it still I
suppose my question is does it still
have the same resonance as it did to
People of Our Generation oh yes it does
massively I mean I visited Hiroshima
many many times over the years I've
spent nearly 40 years dealing with Japan
and I was there for a time as a student
a long time ago
um you can't go to the atomic bomb
Museum without being profoundly moved by
what happened in Hiroshima and it
carries an enormous resonance in the
society particularly because Japan says
to the world look we are the one country
that has been the victim of atomic
attack it carries resonance with with
the Prime Minister kishida because he
comes from Hiroshima so he's going to be
majoring on nuclear disarmament as a
theme of the conference to be frank I
don't think he's going to get very far
with that because the Americans are not
supportive nor are the Germans and with
the threat of nuclear escalation however
real or unreal it may be in Ukraine and
the potential for Chinese aggression in
Taiwan I don't think this is the time at
which people are going to be giving up
their nuclear deterrence but it's going
to be a theme of the way in which
kishuda runs the G7 Mr Ambassador thank
you for your expertise much appreciated
it's a pleasure thank you